SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER
BLAKESBERG. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLEY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LIMON
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMMAT WAHAB. WIENER. WILK
A QUORUM IS PRESENT. SENATORS.
IF WE CAN RETURN TO OUR DESK,
WE'RE GOING TO BE LED IN PRAYER
BY SENATOR PADILLA. AFTER WHICH,
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. SENATOR,
GIVE US ONE SECOND. TURN IT ON.
SORRY YOU'RE ON. WELL. WE'RE ON.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
REFLECTION AND PRAYER. THE NOTED
LYRICIST PENNED, DALE TURNER
PENNED DREAMS ARE RENEWABLE. NO
MATTER WHAT OUR AGE OR
CONDITION, THERE ARE STILL
UNTAPPED POSSIBILITIES WITHIN US
AND NEW BEAUTY WAITING TO BE
BORN. GLORIOUS GOD, TODAY WE
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK OF OUR
SENATE AS WE BRING THE DREAMS
AND HOPES OF MANY TO A WORKABLE
REALITY. MAY WE CONTINUE TO
DISCOVER UNTAPPED POSSIBILITIES
THROUGH OUR CONVERSATION AND
COLLABORATION. MAY WE NURTURE
OUR DREAMS TO FULFILLMENT
THROUGH PATIENT EXPLORATION AND
COURAGEOUS DISCOVERY. MAY WE NOT
GROW TIRED OF OUR EFFORTS TO
BRING PEACE, HEALTH, AND
PROSPERITY TO THE CONSTITUENTS
WHOM WE SERVE. AMEN. AMEN
MEMBERS AND GUESTS, PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE. OF. AS IT
STANDS, ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
GOOD JOB. TO THE KIDS IN THE
GALLERY. MEMBERS. WE HAVE A LOT
OF INTRODUCTIONS TODAY. WE HAVE
A TOTAL OF FIVE INTRODUCTIONS
TODAY, SO LET'S MAKE SURE WE ARE
RUNNING AS SMOOTH AS POSSIBLE.
WE'RE READY. SENATOR JONES, ARE
YOU READY TO KICK US OFF UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WITH
YOUR INTRODUCTION? GOOD MORNING,
MADAM PRESIDENT. NOT YET.
SENATOR GOOD MORNING, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS AND
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY. IT'S AN
HONOR TO KICK OFF OUR
PRESENTATIONS THIS MORNING. AS
YOU HAVE SAID, WE'VE GOT SEVERAL
INTRODUCTIONS, SO LET'S GET
GOING. COLLEAGUES, SENATORS,
EARLIER THIS YEAR, YOU ALL
JOINED ME IN PASSING SCR SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 116 TO
RECOGNIZE SEPTEMBER 20TH 2ND TO
SEPTEMBER 29TH AS FRONTOTEMPORAL
DEGENERATION AWARENESS WEEK.
TODAY, I RISE TO RECOGNIZE SOME
ADVOCATES WHO WORK TIRELESSLY TO
BRING AWARENESS TO THIS TERMINAL
AND INCURABLE NEURO NEURO
DEGENERATIVE DISEASE THAT CAUSES
IMPAIRMENTS TO SPEECH,
PERSONALITY, BEHAVIOR AND MOTOR
SKILLS. ONE OF THE FOLKS THAT WE
ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT IS
CURRENTLY SUFFERING FROM THIS
DISEASE IS BRUCE WILLIS. JOINING
US THIS MORNING IS EMMA WILLIS
HERE ON THE SENATE FLOOR, AND,
JOINING HER ARE SUSAN DICKINSON
FROM THE ASSOCIATION FOR
FRONTOTEMPORAL DEGENERATION AND
WANDA SMITH, A CONSTITUENT OF
MINE IN THE DISTRICT WHO BROUGHT
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE TO OUR
ATTENTION IN THE GALLERY.
JOINING US UPSTAIRS ARE MEMBERS
OF THE WILLIS FAMILY AND OTHER
ADVOCATES THAT ARE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS SITUATION AND WORKING
EVERY DAY TO FIND CURES. THESE
FIERCE ADVOCATES ARE UP HERE
TODAY TO WITNESS THE PASSING OF
SCR 116 AND THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN WILL
BE CARRYING THE SCR IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS. PLEASE JOIN ME THIS
MORNING. PLEASE IN WELCOMING
THIS GROUP OF FIERCE FIGHTERS TO
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE CHAMBERS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION THIS
MORNING. WELCOME. WELCOME TO THE
STATE SENATE.
IF ANY OTHER MEMBER WISHES TO
JOIN IN A GROUP PHOTO, NOW IS
THE TIME.
OUR SECOND INTRODUCTION OF THE
DAY IS LED BY SENATOR NGUYEN AND
SENATOR WAHAB FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR NGUYEN,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I'M
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE QUINN
HARTMAN FROM HUNTING BEACH, MY
DISTRICT, WHO RECENTLY RECEIVED
THE HONOR OF BEING NAMED THE
CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION 2024 SCHOLAR ATHLETE
OF THE YEAR. BUT BEFORE I BRING
HIM ON HERE WITH HIS FAMILY, I
WANT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THE BOARD
MEMBERS AND STAFF OF CIF AS WELL
WHO ARE HERE TO JOIN US. THEY'RE
UP THERE. AS A THREE SPORT
ATHLETE, QUINN HAS DEMONSTRATED
LEADERSHIP AND CHARACTER AS THE
CAPTAIN OF THE SOCCER TEAM,
CROSS COUNTRY AND BASEBALL TEAMS
AT MARINA HIGH SCHOOL. HE ALSO
HAS SERVED IN LEADERSHIP ROLES
IN THE SCIENCE NATIONAL HONOR
SOCIETY AND THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOLARSHIP FEDERATION. HE'S
ALSO A FOUNDING MEMBER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE MARINA MATH
CLUB, AND AS THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE MEDICAL CAREER CLUB.
APART FROM BEING ALL THESE
ACCOMPLISHED ON THE FIELD, HIS
ACHIEVEMENT IN THE CLASSROOM,
INCLUDING COMPLETING ALL 17 AP
CLASSES AT MARINA HIGH SCHOOL BY
HIS JUNIOR YEAR, AND HE HAS ALSO
WAS ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE COLLEGE
BOARD AS AN AP SCHOLAR IN 2022
AND AP SCHOLAR WITH DISTINCTION
IN 2023. ON TOP OF ALL THIS,
QUINN IS ALSO AN AVID VOLUNTEER
IN HIS COMMUNITY, WORKING WITH
YOUTH SPORTS AND AS A BILINGUAL
INTERPRETER FOR THE AQUARIUM OF
THE PACIFIC IN LONG BEACH.
OUTSTANDING YOUNG CALIFORNIANS
LIKE QUINN WHO WHO ADMIRABLY
REPRESENT THEIR GENERATION
THROUGH THEIR TALENTS,
DEDICATION, DETERMINATION,
LEADERSHIP AND POSES THE
INITIATIVE DRIVE TO SUCCEED IN
THEIR PURSUIT. SO PLEASE JOIN ME
IN CONGRATULATING QUINN HARTMAN
AND HIS PARENTS. HIS MOM IS HERE
WITH HIM TODAY. ALLISON HARTMAN
AND HIS YOUNGER BROTHER, OWEN
HARTMAN, WHO IS A FRESHMAN IN
HIGH SCHOOL. AND JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING THEM AND RAISING
SUCH A BRIGHT AND INTELLIGENT
YOUNG MAN WHO HAS A BRIGHT
FUTURE AHEAD OF HIM AND ALL HIS
DEDICATION CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
COMMUNITY. CONGRATULATIONS
QUINN, AND WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE. WE'LL HAVE SENATOR
NGUYEN TAKE THIS PHOTO FIRST
WITH HER SPECIAL GUEST.
I WELCOME ANY OTHER MEMBER WHO
WISHES TO PARTICIPATE IN A GROUP
PHOTO. CAN WE GET ONE MORE? OH.
CONTINUING WITH OUR
INTRODUCTION, SENATOR WAHAB, ARE
YOU READY TO PRESENT OUR NEXT
SCHOLAR ATHLETE OF THE YEAR? YES
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. I
FIRST WANT TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THE MILPITAS PRINCIPAL IS
HERE IN THE GALLERY. GREG
WOLLMANN, NOT EXACTLY SURE
WHERE, BUT THANK YOU. I JUST
WANTED TO HONOR HIM AS WELL. BUT
I'M PROUD TO INTRODUCE OUR NEXT
CIF SCHOLAR ATHLETE, CARISSA
LEE. CARISSA IS A BIT OF A
RENAISSANCE WOMAN. SHE'S THE
CAPTAIN OF THE CROSS COUNTRY
TEAM AT MILPITAS HIGH SCHOOL,
WHERE SHE ALSO PARTICIPATES IN
TRACK AND HAS BEEN A VARSITY
LEVEL ATHLETE FOR FOUR YEARS.
BEYOND THAT, SHE'S A MATHEMATICS
BUFF, PRESIDENT OF THE MATH
CLUB, MATH COMPETITION
PARTICIPANT, AND PROCTOR THREE
TIME QUALIFIER FOR THE AMERICAN
INVITATIONAL MATHEMATICS EXAM.
SO ALL OF YOU GUYS WHO LOVE
MATH, YOU KNOW, SHE'S YOUR GIRL.
A SCHOLAR, HAVING EARNED TWO
TIME AP SCHOLAR WITH
DISTINCTION, NATIONAL MERIT
FINALIST, A COMMUNITY LEADER, A
BOARD OF THE LEADERSHIP
EXPERIENCE, OPPORTUNITY CLUB AT
MILPITAS HIGH SCHOOL, FOUNDED A
LOCAL NONPROFIT PROVIDING
EDUCATION SERVICES FOR STUDENTS
IN GRADES K THROUGH 12. SHE
PLAYS FOUR INSTRUMENTS AND
POSSESSES A QUALITY THAT CANNOT
BE TAUGHT. CURIOSITY A PERSONAL
PROJECT. SHE ANALYZED THE DATA
BEHIND K-POP SURVIVAL REALITY
SHOW BOYS PLANET TO PREDICT
WHICH CONTESTANTS ARE MOST
LIKELY TO WIN AND DEBUT. SHE
GATHERED RAW DATA FROM PUBLIC
SOURCES, CLEANED AND PROCESSED
DATA MANUALLY, AND FILTERED DATA
BASED ON CONTESTANT. THROUGH
SPORTSMANSHIP, SHE HAS HONED HER
SENSE OF TRUSTWORTHINESS,
RESPECT, RESPONSIBILITY, CARING,
FAIRNESS AND CITIZENSHIP. THOSE
SIX PILLARS AND HER INNATE
CURIOSITY WILL TAKE HER FAR.
CONGRATULATIONS TO CARISSA AND
HER ENTIRE FAMILY. CONGRATS,
CARISSA AND WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE.
MEMBERS. NOW IS THE TIME TO
JOIN. IF YOU WISH TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE GROUP PHOTO.
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS OUR THIRD
INTRODUCTION. SENATOR. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I'M VERY
PLEASED TO WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE CHAMBER THIS MORNING, THE
FOURTH GRADE DUAL IMMERSION
CLASS FROM PANTERA ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN DIAMOND BAR THERE IN
SACRAMENTO TODAY, AS PART OF
THEIR ANNUAL TRIP TO LEARN ABOUT
STATE GOVERNMENT AND CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. THEY'RE DIRECTLY ABOVE
ME. LET'S GIVE THEM A WARM
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELCOME, WELCOME, PANTERA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
SENATORS, IF WE CAN TAKE OUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR NOW,
IT'S GETTING A LITTLE LOUD.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, MEMBERS, WE
WILL TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS OUT OF ORDER TODAY.
FILE ITEM 35, SCR 147 AND FILE
ITEM 36 SCR 148. AFTER ADOPTION
OF EACH RESOLUTION, WE WILL
RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR FOR EACH RESPECTIVE AUTHOR
TO INTRODUCE THEIR GUESTS.
SENATOR ASHBY, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR FILE ITEM 35? SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 147 BY
SENATOR ASHBY, RELATIVE TO
FOSTER YOUTH AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR ASHBY, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SCR
147 TODAY, WHICH DESIGNATES THE
MONTH OF MAY AS FOSTER YOUTH
AWARENESS MONTH. IN EVERY CORNER
OF OUR STATE. THERE ARE
COUNTLESS FOSTER YOUTH GROWING
UP IN LOVING, WONDERFUL HOMES.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO FOSTER YOUTH
IN EXTREMELY TRAUMATIZING
SITUATIONS. CALIFORNIA'S
PROVIDERS AND FOSTER FAMILIES
WORK TIRELESSLY TO DELIVER THESE
CARING HOMES, RESOURCES AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO NEARLY
45,000 CHILDREN AND YOUTH EVERY
DAY. CHILDREN OF COLOR, LGBTQ
YOUTH AND YOUTH WITH
DISABILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER NO MATTER THE
DEMOGRAPHIC, HALF OF ALL
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE HAVE
ENDURED FOUR OR MORE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES WHICH
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR
DEVELOPMENT. MANY FOSTER YOUTH
AGE OUT OF THE SYSTEM WITHOUT
THE NECESSARY LIFE SKILLS,
EDUCATION OR SUPPORT NETWORK.
THEY NEED TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THE CHALLENGES OF ADULTHOOD AND
AS A RESULT, THEY DEAL
DISPROPORTIONATELY WITH HOUSING
INSECURITY, ADDICTION AND
POVERTY. AS ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
, 93% OF FOSTER YOUTH SAY THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ATTEND A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE. ONLY 4% OF FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WILL ACTUALLY
OBTAIN THEIR BACHELOR DEGREES.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT LAST YEAR
WE, THE SENATE, TOOK A BIG STEP
FORWARD BY MAKING COLLEGE DEBT
FREE FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
INCLUDING THEIR HOUSING AND
FOOD. BUT IN ORDER TO CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE LIVES OF
FOSTER YOUTH, WE MUST BE
INTENTIONAL, FOCUSED AND INSIST
ON MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES ON
THEIR BEHALF. COLLEAGUES, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN DESIGNATING MAY AS
FOSTER YOUTH AWARENESS MONTH.
VOTING AYE ON SCR ONE, FOUR,
SEVEN AND THE FOLLOWING ONE,
FOUR, EIGHT AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, COMMITTING TO VIEW
EACH PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WE FACE THROUGH THE LENS OF
CREATING PATHWAYS TO SUCCESS FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE, SEN. WAHAB
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SCR 147
FOSTER YOUTH AWARENESS MONTH. AS
THE ONLY PERSON IN THE SENATE
WHO IS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH OF
A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE, I SEE OUR
SYSTEM FROM ALL SIDES, THE GOOD
AND THE BAD. AND I KNOW OUR
SYSTEM HISTORICALLY, AND I WILL
SAY EVEN TODAY HAS ISSUES NØ
ISSUES SEPARATING A CHILD FROM
THEIR PARENTS, WHICH LEADS TO
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES OF COLOR BEING
SEPARATED. BUT I'M ALSO AWARE
THAT THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD
IS TO BE REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME
. FOR EXAMPLE, THOSE CHILDREN
THAT BECOME THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE STATE, A WARD OF THE
STATE AS I WAS, THESE CHILDREN
DESERVE BETTER. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATED ROUGHLY LESS
THAN 3% OF FOSTER YOUTH OBTAIN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE, ROUGHLY 18%
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL. AND THIS,
OF COURSE, SHRINKS WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO PURSUE A HIGHER
EDUCATION DEGREE. AND I'VE HEARD
IT IN THE SENATE. I'VE HEARD IT
IN THE ASSEMBLY, I'VE HEARD IT
EVEN OUTSIDE IN THE REGULAR
WORLD WHERE PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
FOSTER YOUTH AS THE ONLY YOU
KNOW SITUATION THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE IS THAT THEY END
UP INCARCERATED OR THEY HAVE A
DRUG ADDICTION PROBLEM, OR THEY
BECOME A SEX WORKER. THESE ARE
THE STATISTICS AND THE BELIEFS
THAT MANY PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
FOSTER YOUTH END UP BEING A PART
OF, FROM A GOVERNMENT BACKED
SYSTEM. AND IT'S FRUSTRATING
WHEN YOU SEE THAT OVER 40% OF
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE HAVE EDUCATIONAL
DIFFICULTIES, AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND SOME PEOPLE
SAY THEY'RE EMOTIONALLY STUNTED.
I'VE HEARD THIS HERE IN THE
SENATE, AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING TO HEAR THAT. THAT'S
HOW WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHEN
IT'S OUR CHILDREN, OUR SYSTEM
THAT HAS CONSISTENTLY FAILED,
AND WE ARE MAKING STRIDES IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION OF TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT ACCESS TO EDUCATION
IS AVAILABLE. BUT THAT'S THE
BARE MINIMUM. IT'S ROUGHLY
60,000 FOSTER YOUTH IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, AND I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
SHOULD BE HOUSED THEIR ENTIRE
LIFE, A HOME OF THEIR OWN. WE
TALKED IN COVID THAT, HEY, YOU
KNOW, MY KID, MY COUSIN, MY
NEPHEW, MY WHATEVER IS MOVING
BACK IN WITH THEIR PARENTS
BECAUSE COVID HIT, THEY LOST
THEIR JOB, FOSTER YOUTH AND AGED
OUT YOUTH DON'T HAVE THAT LUXURY
. AND WE CONTINUE TO AGAIN GIVE,
GIVE A LOT TO A LOT OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS, INCLUDING OUR VETERANS.
AND YET WE DON'T THINK ABOUT THE
KIDS Tê THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE
SYSTEM FOR YEARS, NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN, BUT THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND SO OUR FOSTER
SYSTEM SHOULD PROVIDE STABILITY
AND SAFETY AND SUPPORT THAT THEY
HAD MISSING AS THEY GROW UP. AND
WE SHOULD ALSO CONTINUE TO HELP
THAT CHILD AS THEY HAVE AGED OUT
OF THE SYSTEM. AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT BUDGET CUTS.
AND THE FIRST THING THAT I'M
ALWAYS LOOKING AT IS, WHAT ARE
WE DOING FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH
THAT DON'T HAVE THE SAFETY NETS,
THAT DON'T HAVE FAMILY, THAT ARE
STEPPING IT? AND IN MY PERSONAL
OPINION, WE ARE STILL NOT DOING
ENOUGH. THEY SHOULD BE THE VERY
FIRST. WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES, BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ADVOCATES, THEY
DON'T HAVE PEOPLE IN THEIR LIVES
THAT ARE ROOTING THEM ON. AND
YES, THERE ARE SOME FOSTER YOUTH
THAT GET LUCKY AND BEAT THE
SYSTEM, BEAT THE STATISTICS,
SOME THAT GET ADOPTED INTO HOMES
THAT ACTUALLY DO CARE ABOUT
THEM. BUT THAT'S NOT EVERYBODY.
SO I ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT FOSTER YOUTH AWARENESS
MONTH, AND LET'S NOT PAINT A
ROSY PICTURE. THE ENTIRE POINT
OF HIGHLIGHTING FOSTER YOUTH
AWARENESS MONTH IS TO HIGHLIGHT
THE WORK THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
DO. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
SENATOR, DO WE HAVE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SENATOR ASHBY, YOU
MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY URGE AN
EYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPERM. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI
AYE. DODD. DORADO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE OR DATO AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OKOBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER. AYES.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WELL
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN CABALLERO. GLAZER
AYE. JONES SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE AYES 37. NO. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. SENATOR
ASHBY, PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
INTRODUCTION OF YOUR SPECIAL
GUEST TODAY. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, YOU ALL OBVIOUSLY
ALREADY KNOW ONE FIERCE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ADVOCATE IN OUR
SENATE COLLEAGUE FROM THE EAST
BAY. I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOU TO A COUPLE MORE, FIRST,
THOUGH, LET ME START BY SAYING
THESE THREE AMAZING YOUNG LADIES
ARE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND NOW
SERVE AS YOUTH ADVOCATES FOR AN
ORGANIZATION YOU ALL KNOW WELL
THE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH. FIRST UP, TANISHA JONES.
TANISHA ATTENDS SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY. SHE'S PURSUING HER
DEGREE IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE. SHE
WAS PREVIOUSLY A YOUTH
AMBASSADOR IN STANISLAUS COUNTY
AND IS WORKING TOWARD OBTAINING
A MASTER'S IN SOCIAL WORK. ALSO
WELCOME WEDNESDAY. POPE
WEDNESDAY ATTENDS FOLSOM LAKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. SHE'S
PURSUING HER DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION, AND SHE
PREVIOUSLY ADVOCATED TO EXPAND
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR ALL FOSTER
YOUTH AT HER COLLEGE. SHE PLANS
TO TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY, AND ROSELLA WILHELM
ATTENDS AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE,
IS PURSUING A DEGREE IN FUNERAL
DIRECTORY. SHE STRONGLY BELIEVES
IN ENSURING THAT OUR LOVED ONES
EXPERIENCE DIGNITY AND HONOR,
EVEN IN THEIR PASSING.
COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING AND RECOGNIZING THESE
THREE OUTSTANDING YOUNG LADIES
WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED INCREDIBLE
PERSEVERANCE AS WELL AS THE
OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE THAT YOU WILL
MEET TODAY DURING FOSTER YOUTH
AWARENESS MONTH. THE STATE
SENATE WELCOMES THESE THREE
FIERCE ADVOCATES.
GROUP PHOTO TIME. IF YOU WISH TO
PARTICIPATE.
SENATOR ASHBY, I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ONE MORE INTRODUCTION. I
DO, MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH SCR 147, I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE A FEW
VERY IMPORTANT PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WORK
TIRELESSLY TO ADVOCATE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES IN OUR
GALLERY TODAY, WE HAVE ADRIAN
SHELTON, THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY AND STRATEGY FOR
THE ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE HAVE KAT BEST,
POLICY AND REGULATOR, REGULATORY
ANALYST FOR THE ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES. WE
HAVE AMANDA KIRSHNER, THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY
FOR THE CHILD WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION, EILEEN KUBINSKI,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. AND SIMONE TORELLI,
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AND HEALTH
FOR THE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOUTH. I'D LIKE TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING TO THE SENATE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 36.
SENATOR ALVARADO HILL PREPARED.
SHE IS READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 148 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO RELATIVE TO FOSTER CARE
AWARENESS MONTH. SENATOR THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO WITH A
WONDERFUL INTRODUCTION. I AM
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 148, WHICH
WILL DECLARE THE MONTH OF MAY
2024 AS FOSTER CARE AWARENESS
MONTH. THIS RESOLUTION RAISES
AWARENESS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN, NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEXITIES OF OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM, AND DECLARES THAT EVERY
CHILD DESERVES A SAFE, STABLE
HOME WITH NURTURING RESPONSIBLE
ADULTS AS THEIR PROTECTORS. I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LIFE EXPERIENCES AND SHARED
WISDOM OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD. ACCORDING TO UC
BERKELEY'S CALIFORNIA CHILD
WELFARE INDICATORS PROJECT,
NEARLY 100 TIMES A DAY, A CHILD
IN CALIFORNIA IS PLACED IN
FOSTER CARE. THIS CONTRIBUTES TO
AN AVERAGE OF 60,000 CHILDREN IN
OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. IN FACT,
IN ANY GIVEN YEAR, 700,000
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA ARE IN
CONTACT WITH THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. CHILDREN WHO ARE
FORCEFULLY REMOVED FROM THEIR
HOMES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE ABUSE, NEGLECT AND
OTHER ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES, OR ACES, LEADING TO
CHRONIC SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM,
HOMELESSNESS, AND ENCOUNTERS
WITH THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. EMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES
AND BOTH IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS. AND IT IS
NO SECRET THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HELP TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS,
WE MUST RELY ON ALLOCATIONS
THROUGH OUR BUDGET, WHICH THIS
YEAR WE'RE HAVING TO MAKE VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS. AS
CALIFORNIA HAS SPEARHEADED
PROFOUND REFORMS BY ENHANCING
ASSESSMENTS FOR PERSONALIZED
SUPPORT AND PRIORITIZING FAMILY
BASED CARE, FOSTERING A MORE
COMPASSIONATE AND EFFECTIVE
SYSTEM. THESE EFFORTS REFLECT A
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND STABILITY
FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH AND
FAMILIES, DRIVING POSITIVE
CHANGE ACROSS THE STATE. AS
CHAIR OF SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
DESIGNATING MAY 2024 AS FOSTER
CARE AWARENESS MONTH TO ENSURE
SUPPORTIVE AND EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO BE
DEVELOPED AND IMPROVED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR
HER HARD WORK ON OUR BUDGET AS
OUR BUDGET CHAIR, IN HAVING TO
HELP NAVIGATE HOW OUR FUNDING
THIS YEAR WILL HELP TO SUPPORT
OUR PROGRAMS. AS I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION, A YOUTH LED
ORGANIZATION THAT DEVELOPS YOUNG
LEADERS TO TRANSFORM FOSTER CARE
THROUGH COMMUNITY LED ORGANIZING
, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY, AND
POLICY GUIDANCE TO IMPLEMENT
REAL AND IMPACTFUL CHANGE. THANK
YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTIONS ADVOCACY OVER THE
LAST 30 YEARS, AND TO TELL ALL
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS AND FOSTER
FAMILIES WORKING TO BETTER THE
LIVES OF ALL FOSTER YOUTH HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
KINDLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SCR 148. THANK YOU. SENATOR, DO
WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON FILE ITEM 36? THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
DO WE HAVE ANY OBJECTION? AYES
37. NO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR ALVARADO
HILL, YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
WITH ME TODAY, I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTIONS, CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTIONS, LEGISLATIVE TEAM,
OUR LEAD, CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ,
AND CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
MEMBERS CLARISSA PENA, ELIANA
PENA, JESSICA FUENTES, AMBER HèA
, SHEILA DE LA MUJER, ETHAN
BENAVIDES, MALACHI PETERSON, AND
TYLER ZINO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. OUR YOUTH
HERE IS CARRYING THE FLAG FOR
ALL FOSTER YOUTH AND HELPING TO
BRING THE VOICE OF FOSTER YOUTH
TO THE LEGISLATIVE FLOOR AND IN
POLICY DECISIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY.
WELCOME TO OUR YOUNG WARRIORS.
OUR YOUNG WARRIORS HERE.
IF ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO BE IN
THIS PHOTO, NOW IS THE TIME.
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. NOW
MOVING ON TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SENATOR
SATO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. YEP.
OKAY, AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILL FROM CONSENT A B
1946, WHICH IS ITEM 66. THE DESK
WILL NOTE, PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 29.10 C, THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE ITEM 21
AB 1359. NOW INTO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. UNDER SECOND
READING FILE, WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH 21. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1778 WITH
AMENDMENTS 1904, 1924, 1953, 25,
36, 28, 1226. SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ UNDER
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WE HAVE ONE
ITEM ONLY FILE ITEM 23. SENATOR
GAROZZO, ARE YOU PREPARED?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 828 BY SENATOR DORADO. AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
OSO, THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS, I AM HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 828, WHICH IS AN
URGENCY MEASURE THAT MOVES THE
START DATE OF THE HEALTH CARE
MINIMUM WAGE BY ONE MONTH FROM
JUNE 1ST TO JULY 1ST, 2024. SB
525. AS YOU RECALL, PROVIDED A
WAGE INCREASE TO MORE THAN
400,000 HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
MAINLY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR, WHO TAKE CARE OF US, TOOK
CARE OF US AND KEEP OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM FUNCTIONING. IT IS
CLEAR THAT THESE WORKERS NEED
THIS IN ORDER TO HELP SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES. I ALSO WANT TO
GIVE GREAT APPRECIATION TO THE
HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS THAT
RECOGNIZE THIS AND HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN TO INCREASE WAGES. THIS
BILL ALIGNS SB 525 WITH THE
BUDGET YEAR. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, DO WE
HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM 23? SENATOR NILO,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I GUESS ONE
COULD SAY THIS IS PUZZLING, BUT
THEN AGAIN, MAYBE NOT. THIS IS
HORRIBLE POLICY. AS I
ARTICULATED WHEN THE ORIGINAL
BILL WAS INTRODUCED. THIS NOT
ONLY CAUSES AN INCREASE IN WAGES
AT THE LOWEST, LOWER, LOWEST END
OF, HEALTH CARE INSTITUTE MEANS,
BUT ALL THE WAY UP THE CHAIN,
BECAUSE OF THE REALITY OF WAGE
COMPACTION. NUMBER ONE, AND THE
FACT THAT EXEMPT EMPLOYEES HAVE
TO BE GUARANTEED DOUBLE THE
MINIMUM WAGE RATE, CALCULATING
IT ON A 2080 HOUR, ANNUAL PAY
THAT BY THE WAY, IS $104,000 A
YEAR, MINIMUM WAGE FOR EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES. I HAVE TO SAY, I WAS
PUZZLED WHEN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
THIS BILL IN THE FIRST PLACE,
BECAUSE HE HAD VETOED OTHER
BILLS THAT HAD AN IMPACT ON THE
STATE BUDGET, FRANKLY, ARGUABLY
A LOWER IMPACT THAN THIS BILL
EVENTUALLY WILL. AND THEN IT WAS
SHORTLY AFTER THAT THAT I
REMEMBER HE KIND OF SAID, OOPS,
AND NOW WE'RE WORKING TO DELAY
THESE WAGE INCREASES. NOW, FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE ME, IT'S DIFFICULT
TO KNOW WHETHER TO VOTE YES OR
NO. YES MEANING DELAY IT BECAUSE
IT'S BAD POLICY IN THE FIRST
PLACE. NO BECAUSE I WAS OPPOSED
TO THE POLICY AND THEREFORE I
OPPOSE THIS. I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY ELSE IS SIMILARLY
CONFUSED, BUT THIS IS JUST BAD
POLICY. AND FRANKLY, THE ONLY
ROUTE IS TO COMPLETELY REPEAL
THE BILL ALTOGETHER. SO I WILL
JUST BE LAYING OFF. DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR OSO, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR WILK. APOLOGIZE. SENATOR
WILK, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. YEAH.
THAT WAS, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I KNOW IT'S THURSDAY,
SO I'M NOT GOING TO GO ON AND
ON, BUT I WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THE BUDGET, THE
BUDGET. VICE CHAIRMAN, I HAVE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT TAKE,
THOUGH. OUT OF THE SEVEN
HOSPITALS IN MY DISTRICT, TWO OF
THEM ARE QUITE CONFIDENT. IF
THIS IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED, THEY
WILL BE OUT OF BUSINESS WITHIN A
YEAR. SO EVEN THOUGH I DIDN'T
SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL POLICY AND
IT'D BE NICE TO JUST WATCH THE
GOVERNOR DANGLE, THIS IS GOING
TO ALLOW MY HOSPITALS TO STAY
OPEN AT LEAST ANOTHER MONTH, SO
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
BUT VERY CONFLICTED ABOUT IT. A
RELUCTANT I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
DISCUSSION I'M SEEING NONE.
HEARING NONE. SENATOR DEROSA,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUE. AGAIN, TODAY IS NOT
ABOUT, ANY PARTICULARS OF SB
525. TODAY IS SIMPLY TO MOVE THE
START DATE FROM JUNE 1ST TO JULY
1ST. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI.
DODD AYE. DORADO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBEN SATO. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
SKINNER. HI. SMALL GUAVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMMER AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN. CABALLERO. DALY GROVE.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
OKOBO. SATO. AYES 31. NÓ ZERO.
ON THE URGENCY. EYES 31. NO.
ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
UNDER SENATE. THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS 30 AND 39. SENATOR RUBIO
ARE PREPARED FOR ITEM 30. SHE IS
READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 92 BY SENATOR
RUBIO, RELATIVE TO LUPUS AND
FIBROMYALGIA AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SR 92, WHICH PROCLAIMS
MAY 2024 AS LUPUS AND
FIBROMYALGIA AWARENESS MONTH.
BOTH LUPUS AND FIBROMYALGIA ARE
CHRONIC, LONG LASTING DISORDERS
THAT CAUSE SEVERE PAIN
THROUGHOUT THE BODY. IN THE
UNITED STATES, THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED 1.5 MILLION PEOPLE
DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS AND OVER 4
MILLION PEOPLE DIAGNOSED WITH
FIBROMYALGIA. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT WOMEN WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR DOMESTIC ABUSE
ARE ALMOST TWICE AS LIKELY TO
DEVELOP FIBROMYALGIA.
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME,
THERE IS NO CURE FOR EITHER ONE
OF THEM. SR 92 WILL HELP TO
EXPAND PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION OF LUPUS AND
FIBROMYALGIA, WITH THE HOPE OF
PROVIDING PATIENTS WITH BETTER
TREATMENT AND FUTURE CARE. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT LU█N FOR LUPUS
, AN ORGANIZATION IN MY DISTRICT
WHO WORKS TIRELESSLY TO NOT ONLY
BRING AWARENESS, BUT REALLY
PROVIDE RESOURCES THAT ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THOSE IN
NEED. AND I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COAUTHORS, WHICH DOES HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THEY'VE
JOINED ME IN SUPPORTING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY DISCUSSION ON
DEBATE ON ITEM 30? SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE OR DATO AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEUMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OKOBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL GRAVIS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN JONES. AYES
37. NO. ZERO RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEM 39. SENATOR
ALVARADO ALVARADO. HILL ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 97 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS APPRECIATION MONTH.
SENATOR THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. PERMISSION TO USE A
PROP WITHOUT OBJECTION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION 97,
WHICH GIVES THANKS TO CALIFORNIA
FAIRS BY DESIGNATING MAY 2024 AS
FAIR GROUND APPRECIATION MONTH.
NOW, YOU MIGHT WONDER HOW YOU
HERE IN THE SENATE, CAN EARN A
BEAUTIFUL, TEJANA OR HAT OR A
BELT BUCKLE? WELL, THESE ARE
TROPHIES THAT ARE GIVEN OUT AT
THE FAIR FOR SOME TIMES, LASTING
EIGHT SECONDS ON A RIDE,
SOMETIMES HAVING THE WINNING
LIVESTOCK IN THE ARENA AND OTHER
TIMES TO SHOW LEADERSHIP. WELL,
AS A FRESHMAN SENATOR, I THINK
I'VE EARNED MY EIGHT SECONDS
BEING BUCKED WITH A B. ALL
RIGHT, SO CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
76 DIFFERENT FAIRGROUNDS THAT
SERVE THE ENTIRE STATE IN SENATE
DISTRICT FOUR. WHETHER IT'S
BOOTS, BARROWS AND BLING IN EL
DORADO, ZINFANDEL AND ZINNIAS IN
AMADOR, OR, AS WE KNOW, LIFE
HAPPENS AT THE FAIR IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY, OUR FAIRS
GENERATE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR NONPROFITS, YOUTH
ORGANIZATIONS, SCHOOLS, CITIES,
COUNTIES, SMALL BUSINESSES, AND
THE STATE. DID YOU KNOW THAT THE
LIVESTOCK AUCTION GENERATES
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
FOR YOUTH SCHOLARSHIPS? THESE
ARE YOUTH THAT, AS YOUNG AS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ARE DEDICATED
TO RAISING LIVESTOCK, STEER
SWINE TURKEYS, RABBITS AND OTHER
GOATS AND SHEEP IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO EARN MONEY FOR COLLEGE,
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO EARN MONEY
FOR TRADE SCHOOL. IT GIVES OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ENTREPRENEURS AND IT GIVES
THE COMMUNITY SOME REALLY GREAT,
HEALTHY MEAT, THERE'S ALSO
COMPETITIONS WHERE IF YOUR
COMPETITIVE SPIRIT COMES OUT AND
YOU WANT TO BRING YOUR BEST
FLORAL ARRANGEMENT OR YOUR BEST
BAKED GOODS AND JAMS, YOU CAN DO
THAT AS WELL. IN MY OFFICE,
WE'VE WON SEVERAL RIBBONS FOR
OUR BAKED GOODS AND JAMS AND ME,
MYSELF HAVE WON SEVERAL RIBBONS
IN TABLE SETTING. YES, I AM A
CALIFORNIA AWARDED TABLE SETTING
COMPETITOR. HOWEVER, OUR
FAIRGROUNDS ARE SO MUCH MORE
THAN JUST AN ANNUAL EVENT WHERE
YOU CAN FIND THE VERY BEST
KETTLE CORN. OUR FAIRGROUNDS
ALSO SERVE AS MAKESHIFT
HOSPITALS, EVACUATION CENTERS
DURING FIRES, AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS, VACCINATION SITES,
AND SO MUCH MORE. OUR COUNTY
FAIRS EMBODY OUR COMMUNITY AND I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS TO OUR STATE. NOW, MANY OF
YOU ARE PROBABLY ASKING ME,
WHAT'S THIS BOOK THAT WE HAVE ON
OUR DESK TODAY? THE CELEBRATED
JUMPING FROG BY MARK TWAIN?
WELL, MARK TWAIN HIMSELF VISITED
CALAVERAS COUNTY IN MY DISTRICT
IN ANGELS CAMP AND HEARD THE
STORY OF THE JUMPING FROG AND
MANY OF YOU HAVE NOW
PARTICIPATED IN OUR ANNUAL EVENT
HERE AT THE CAPITOL. NOW I SEE
OUR PRESIDENT OVER THERE
SMILING. THAT'S BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY, FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
JOCKEYED HER FROG HERE AT THE
CAPITOL. AND ALONG WITH THAT, MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WAS
ALSO, FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME,
WAS ABLE TO JOCKEY HER FIRST
FROG, WHICH, YES, IT MEANS YOU
TOUCH A FROG AND YOU LET IT LEAP
FORWARD FOR THE COMPETITION.
WELL, THIS YEAR I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOS
ANGELES THREE OF US AND HER
TEAM, WHICH WON WITH THEIR FROG
DUA LIPA, THE COMPETITION WITH A
JUMP OF 12FT, NINE INCHES. AND
THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR THAT
THEY HOLD THIS TITLE. SO MEMBERS
IN THE SENATE, WE'VE GOT SOME
COMPETITION IN THE ASSEMBLY.
HAHA, THEY I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE HAD THE
INTERNATIONAL FROG TEAM FINALS
IN CALAVERAS AND AN 89 YEAR OLD
GRANDMOTHER OF GUSTINE. THIS IS
SIX GENERATIONS OF FAMILIES
JUMPING FROGS. THE TEAM FROM
MERCED WON THE BRAGGING RIGHTS
FOR THE FARTHEST JUMPING FROG,
SO CONGRATULATIONS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MERCED FOR THE
BRAGGING RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
FOR THE FARTHEST JUMPING JOCKEY
IN CALIFORNIA. VÀ. NOW, I KNOW
THAT THIS IS A LOT OF FUN, AND
I'M HOPING THAT YOU WILL ENJOY
WHAT I'M SHARING WITH YOU TODAY
AND TAKE IT TO YOUR OWN FAIRS.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES SHARED TODAY THAT FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE COVID, SHE
AND HER FAMILY WENT TO THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FAIR AND HAD A
WONDERFUL TIME. SO REMEMBER, THE
FAIRS ARE NOT JUST ABOUT, NOT
JUST ABOUT CENTERS FOR
COMMUNITY, BUT IT'S THE
EMBODIMENT OF FAMILY. NOW, I
WANT TO INVITE ALL OF YOU TO
VISIT OUR DISPLAY IN ROOM 215,
WHICH IS A QUILT DESIGNED AND
SEWN BY THE SIERRA QUILT GUILD
OF TUOLUMNE COUNTY IN SONORA.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF TUOLUMNE
COUNTY HAVE PUT TOGETHER A
BEAUTIFUL SCENIC DISPLAY OF
CALIFORNIA SIERRAS, AND THIS
WILL ALSO BE AUCTIONED AT THE
UPCOMING MOTHER LODE FAIR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR YOUR VERY COLORFUL
PRESENTATION ON YOUR, ITEM.
SENATOR EGGMAN, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT, I RISE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. AND
ALSO TO ANNOUNCE IF PEOPLE HAVE
HAD YOUR INTEREST PIQUED BY THAT
CONVERSATION THIS WEEKEND,
STARTING FRIDAY. SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY IS A SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
FAIR RESURGENCE. YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN IT ON TV, WINE, BEER, THE
MARY JANE BLIGE GIRLS. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE IT ALL. SO PLEASE
COME ON OUT TO SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS THIS WEEKEND.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR DALY
FROM. SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, I'M PULLING A PRO TEM
MOVE. HE NEVER GIVES HIS BILLS
FROM HIS OWN DESK. I WANT TO
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF, SR 97.
SOME OF YOU WHO REPRESENTS 15
COUNTIES, 15 COUNTY FAIRS, AND
SEVERAL DISTRICT FAIRS, IT'S A
GREAT COMMUNITY DRIVER. THEY
ACTUALLY GENERATE MONEY FOR THE
STATE. THAT'S ANOTHER DEBATE FOR
ANOTHER DAY. WE WENT DOWN THAT
ROAD MANY TIMES BUT ALSO STAND
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD,bNATOR
GROVE. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. YOU
KNOW, MOST OF THESE FAIRS
THROUGHOUT OUR DISTRICTS HAVE
RODEOS IN THEM WHERE THE
LEGENDARY COTTON ROSSER HAS A
STOCK CONTRACTOR FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THESE FAIRS THAT
PROVIDE RODEO ENTERTAINMENT. HIS
SON RENO HAS TAKEN OVER THAT
WONDERFUL BUSINESS. THEY
ACTUALLY DO A LOT OF, EXHIBITS
HERE ON THE STATE CAPITOL, AND
WE HAVE FARM AND AG DAY OR AG
DAY AT THE CAPITOL, AND THEY
RAISE SOME OF THE MOST
PHENOMENAL LIVESTOCK THAT
ENTERTAINS MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE AND, AND OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES AS WELL. AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT JUST,
RECENTLY, WE, RECENTLY AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO GET OFF THIS
SUBJECT MATTER, BUT RENO ROSSER,
I CALLED HIM BECAUSE THERE WAS A
GROUP OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS THAT WANTED TO RIDE A
HORSE, AND WE RECENTLY TOOK THEM
OUT TO THE RANCH JUST HERE IN
MARYSVILLE. AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO GET ON A 1,200 POUND ANIMAL
AND RIDE A HORSE. AND THEY HAD
THE BEST DAY, I KNOW THAT THEY
DO THINGS LIKE THAT. THEY ALSO
DO A LOT OF THINGS WITH FOSTER
YOUTH. WHEN THEY HAD THE FIRES
DOWN IN LOS ANGELES, THERE WAS A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS THAT COME UP
FROM THE LA AREA TO WORK FOR THE
ROSSER FAMILY, AND THEY PROVIDED
THEM GREAT WAGES. THEY PROMOTE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO PURSUE A
RODEO CAREER, WHEN THEY HAVE THE
SKILL AND ABILITY TO DO SO. AND
IT CREATES JOBS FOR THEM. AND I
JUST APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD, BECAUSE WE
NEED TO PROTECT OUR FAIRS AND WE
NEED TO PROTECT OUR RODEOS. AND
THEY DO PROVIDE A WONDERFUL
SOURCE OF ENTERTAINMENT AND A
WONDERFUL SOURCE OF INCOME AND
REVENUE TO OUR DISTRICT. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR BLAKE, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. YES. THANK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT MIKE IS NOT ON
YET. HELLO IT'S STILL NOT
WORKING. GIVE US A MINUTE,
SENATOR. OKAY OKAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU. PRESIDENT. I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FAIRGROUNDS AND SAY THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
TODAY. I HAVE A PROSPEROUS ONE
IN MY DISTRICT AT DEL MAR. SERVE
A MILLION PEOPLE VISIT THERE.
THERE'S A FAIR. THERE'S A
THOROUGHBRED RACE CLUB, AND I
WENT THERE AS A CHILD, AND WE
HAVE ALL SORTS OF MUSIC THAT'S
THERE. AND WE'RE ALSO ABOUT TO
HAVE A RECYCLING CENTER AND A
REALLY IMPORTANT, CIRCULAR
ECONOMY PORTION ON THE
FAIRGROUNDS. SO I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING IT UP. SENATOR DURAZO,
I JUST WANT TO ADD A LITTLE BIT
OF, TO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE, WHEN I WENT THIS
WEEKEND, I SAW EVERYTHING FROM A
LOWRIDER PARADE THROUGHOUT THE,
THE FAIR TO THE CONCERT OF LOS
TUCANES FOR ANYBODY WHO KNOWS
THEM, AND, OF COURSE, GREAT
FOOD. AND THEN THERE'S GREASY
FOOD, DEEP FRIED BATCH, PIECE OF
BUTTER. SO IMAGINE WHAT THAT
WOULD TASTE LIKE, AND ALL KINDS
OF GOODIES LIKE THAT. I GOT ON
THE ROLLER COASTER WITH MY
GRANDKIDS, SO YOU CAN DO ALL
SORTS OF THINGS THAT GET YOUR
MIND OFF. I'M GLAD I MADE IT
BEFORE IT CLOSED. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO SPEAK ON
THEIR FAIR IN THEIR COUNTY?
SENATOR RUBIO, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. WELL, WE CANNOT
LEAVE THE POMONA FAIRPLEX, ONE
OF THE RESPECTFULLY BEST, IN OUR
STATE. AND SO I INVITE ALL OF
YOU TO COME AND VISIT. IT DOES
PROVIDE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOOD, GAMES, FAMILY. AND BOY, DO
YOU SEE GENERATIONS COME
TOGETHER JUST TO BE WITH EACH
OTHER. SO WHAT A WONDERFUL
RESOLUTION AND THANK YOU. AND I
ADD MY VOICE TO IT. SEEING ALL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE AND
SENATOR ALVARADO, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR RECOGNIZING THEIR
AFFAIRS. AND I AWAIT INVITATIONS
TO THEIR COUNTY FAIRS. AND I
ALWAYS HAVE AN OPEN INVITATION
TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO COME TO
OUR COUNTY FAIRS. I'VE GOT
TICKETS FOR YOU, AND I WILL MAKE
SURE THAT YOU COME AND HAVE THE
BEST TIME OF YOUR YEAR, I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DID NOT ALSO,
THANK, THE TURNER FAMILY WITH
THE FAMOUS 20 MULE CART, 2020
PULL MULE CART, IN INYO COUNTY,
WHICH I WAS ABLE TO RIDE THIS
LAST WEEKEND. AND MY FELLOW
RIDERS WHO CONTINUE TO MAKE OUR
FAIRS, PART OF COMMUNITY, PART
OF THE AG COMMUNITY, PART OF THE
LIVESTOCK COMMUNITY. AND OUR
WONDERFUL WRITERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I'LL RODA-GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY.
AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE
. AYES 37. NO ZERO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. ON DECK.
COLLEAGUES, IS A SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER 37, WITH ITEM 68
THROUGH 76. IS THERE ANY ITEM A
MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ALL ITEMS 68 THROUGH
76. SENATE RESOLUTION 87.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
146 159 161, 179, 183, 185, 188,
189. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE FIRST ITEM. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABILDO CORTEZ.
DALIA. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. AYE. NGUYEN. AYES 37.
NO. ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS APPROVED. MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS, WE HAVE
FIVE SUB BUDGET COMMITTEES
MEETING AFTER SENATOR LAIRD.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. SUBCOMMITTEE,
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 2100. IN THE
SWING SPACE. SENATOR BECKER,
YOUR. SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED BY BUDGET. SUB TWO
WILL MEET IN ROOM 2215 MINUTES
AFTER GERMAN. THANK YOU. BUDGET
SUB THREE WILL MEET IN ROOM 1215
MINUTES AFTER SESSION. SENATOR
PADILLA, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR
ON STATE ADMINISTRATION AND
GOVERNMENT WILL CONVENE HERE IN
THE CAPITOL ROOM 113, 15 MINUTES
FOLLOWING ADJOURNMENT. SENATOR
WAHAB, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU. BUDGET SUB FIVE WILL MEET
IN ROOM 112, ROUGHLY TEN MINUTES
AFTER CLOSE OF SESSION.
SENATORS, WE HAVE ONE ANOTHER
ITEM THAT WE WILL NEED. EVERYONE
HERE FOR. IF WE COULD RETURN
BACK TO OUR DESK MEMBERS, WE ARE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
FOR SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR HER
PROCEDURAL MOTION. MAJORITY
LEADER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
MOVE TO WITHDRAW AB 1955 FROM
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND RE
REFER THE MEASURE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SENATOR WILK, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO AMEND THAT MOTION ON THE
FLOOR TO HAVE AB 1955 TO BE
REFERRED TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY, AB 1955 HAS A
DIRECT IMPACT ON THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS OF PARENTS TO OVERSEE AND
CONTROL THE UPBRINGING OF THEIR
CHILDREN, AND SHOULD PROPERLY BE
HEARD IN SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BEFORE BEING
CONSIDERED IN A SENATE AND
SENATE APPROVES. THIS BILL WAS
HEARD YESTERDAY IN THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND WAS QUITE CLEAR
THAT THERE IS VERY IMPORTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL AND PRIVACY
ISSUES INVOLVED, AND IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO GO TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. MADAM
PRESIDENT, THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR WILK HAS MADE A MOTION
TO MOVE 19 SB AB 1955 TO YOU,
SENATOR WILK IS ASKING FOR A AYE
VOTE MAJORITY LEADER, SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN.
AYE. RODA-GIL ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
NO. ATKINS NO. BECKER. I NO.
BECKER. NO. BLAKE. SPEER NO.
BRADFORD. NO. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
NO DALLY. I DODD. NO. DURAZZO.
NO EGGMAN. NO. GLAZER. NO
GONZALEZ. NO. GROVE I HURTADO.
NO NO. JONES I LAIRD. NO. LIMON
NO. MCGUIRE. NO NO. MENGIBAR.
NO. MIN NO. NEWMAN. NO. WHEN
NILO I COBO I PADILLA. NO.
PORTANTINO NO. ROTH NO. RUBIO
NO. SATO I. SKINNER NO. SMALL.
CUEVAS I. STERN. NO SMALL.
CUEVAS I TO NOW. STERN. NO.
UMBERG NO. WAHAB NO. WIENER. NO.
WILK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN ALL. RODA-GIL. NO
ARCHULETA. NO CABALLERO. NGUYEN
I 730. NOES! THE MOTION FAILS.
MOVING BACK TO THE MOTION FROM
MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR GONZALEZ
, WE GOT ONE MORE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION? SEEING
NONE. AYES 37. NO, ZERO. THE
MOTION PASSES. NOW WE'RE
RETURNING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTION. THIS IS A TIME FOR
OUR ADJOURN IN MEMORIES. AS
SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED AND COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR BECKER, GIVE ME A MINUTE
. PETE MCCLOSKEY. SENATORS, WE
ARE NOW MOVING INTO ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES FOR RESPECT OF THE
FAMILIES, OF THE LOST
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE WILL
RECOGNIZE TODAY. PLEASE RETURN
TO OUR DESK OR TAKE OUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TODAY TO HONOR FORMER
PENINSULA CONGRESSMAN PAUL
NORTON. PETE MCCLOSKEY, WHO
PASSED AWAY EARLIER IN MAY. HE
WAS ELECTED AS A REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTING THE PENINSULA IN
1967. AND PETE REPRESENTED THE
BEST PART OF POLITICS. HE WAS
KNOWN AS A MAN OF PRINCIPLE
LOCALLY AS WELL AS NATIONALLY.
HE GRADUATED FROM STANFORD AND
THEN SERVED OUR COUNTRY IN THE
MARINE CORPS IN KOREA, TAKING
BULLETS IN THE LEG WHILE LEADING
BAYONET CHARGES. IN THAT WAR.
PRIOR TO ENTERING CONGRESS, HE
WAS AN ATTORNEY WHO TOOK ON
CASES FOR THOSE WITHOUT A VOICE.
CONGRESSMAN MCCLOSKEY CENTERED
HIS WORK ON THE COMMUNITY. HE
SPOKE FOR PEACE EVEN WHEN IT WAS
UNPOPULAR TO DO SO, AND LOUDLY
CAME OUT AGAINST THE VIETNAM
WAR. HE SPOKE UP AGAINST
CORRUPTION AS WELL. HE WAS
ACTUALLY THE FIRST CONGRESS
MEMBER TO CALL FOR PRESIDENT
NIXON'S IMPEACHMENT. AFTER THE
NEWS OF WATERGATE BROKE. HE ALSO
AND AGAIN AS A REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTATIVE PENINSULA. HE WAS
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AND CLIMATE AND
ACTUALLY ESTABLISHED THE VERY
FIRST EARTH DAY IN 1960S. HE WAS
CO-FOUNDER OF THE VERY FIRST
EARTH DAY. HE WAS ALSO VERY
INVOLVED IN GOOD GOVERNMENT. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHERE I HAD THE
CHANCE TO WORK WITH HIM, WORKING
WITH THE CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
AND CLEAN MONEY INITIATIVES. AND
THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HIM, ALL THROUGHOUT THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES, PETE JOINED
THE COQUETTE LAW FIRM IN EARLY
2000, WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
RESPECTED FIRMS IN OUR AREA,
WORKING ON, WORKING IN THE
PUBLIC GOOD. HE WORKED AS A
LAWYER, REPRESENTING THOSE THAT
WERE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF, AND HE
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT PROTECTING
THE ENVIRONMENT AND SOCIAL
WELL-BEING, I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN
ME IN SENDING CONDOLENCES TO HIS
WIFE, HELEN, AND THEIR FAMILIES.
MAY PETE'S MEMORY FOREVER BE A
BLESSING. SENATOR LAIRD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, I JOIN IN ADJOURNING
IN MEMORY FOR, FORMER
CONGRESSMAN PETE MCCLOSKEY. I'VE
HEARD MANY OF US TALK PRIVATELY,
AND WE ALL SEEM TO HAVE A SUMMER
INTERNSHIP EXPERIENCE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C, MINE WAS WITH
PETE MCCLOSKEY. AND IT WAS NOT
JUST ANY INTERNSHIP. IT WAS IN
HIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN. HE
CHOSE TO RUN IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES AGAINST RICHARD NIXON.
AND I WORKED FOR HIM IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND IN WASHINGTON,
D.C, AND IT WAS VERY PRINCIPLED
STAND AT THE TIME. HE AND MY
FUTURE BOSS, CONGRESSMAN JERRY
WALDIE, BOTH TRAVELED TO
SOUTHEAST ASIA AND CAME BACK AND
THOUGHT WE WERE IN A SITUATION
THAT COULD NOT GO FORWARD. AND
SO HE NOT ONLY, BECAME ONE OF
THE FIRST REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO OPPOSE THE WAR, HE
TOOK THE PRINCIPLED STEP OF
CHALLENGING RICHARD NIXON IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES. AND
WHILE HE GOT WASHED OUT BIG
TIME, HE PLANTED THE FLAG IN A
WAY THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT. AND
ON WHICH HISTORY REFLECTS VERY
WELL. AND PART OF HIS EXPERIENCE
WAS, AS WAS MENTIONED, HE FOUGHT
IN KOREA, KOREA AND HE HAS
WRITTEN A BOOK THAT I HAVE
SOMEWHERE ON HIS, SPECIFIC
BATTLEFIELD EXPERIENCE WITH HIS
PLATOON. AND THE OTHER THING
THAT DIDN'T GET MENTIONED VERY
CLEARLY IS WHEN HE WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO CONGRESS, THE PERSON
HE BEAT IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY WAS FORMER CHILD ACTOR
SHIRLEY TEMPLE. AND THE BOOK
ABOUT THAT RACE WAS CALLED THE
SINKING OF THE LOLLIPOP. IT WAS
WRITTEN BY SOMEONE WHOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS STILL LIVE IN MY
DISTRICT. AND IT WAS JUST TRUE
TO FORM, STAKING A FLAG, RUNNING
ON A PRINCIPLED STAND, WINNING
THE IMPOSSIBLE RACE. AND IN HIS
LATER YEARS, HE WAS ON A FARM IN
THE CAPAY VALLEY, WAS A NEIGHBOR
OF MY BROTHER'S, WAS A WELL
KNOWN PRESENCE AT THE ALMOND
FESTIVAL. THEY BOTH HAD TO FEND
OFF FIRES AND JUST OVERALL, HE
WAS A PATRIOT. HE WAS A FAMILY
MAN. HE WAS PRINCIPLED. HE WAS A
GOOD NEIGHBOR. HE WAS A GOOD
FRIEND. I THINK HE WILL LIVE IN
HISTORY AS ONE OF THE FINER
PROFILES IN COURAGE IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS. I JOIN
IN THE MEMORY OF PETE MCCLOSKEY.
SEMPER FIDELIS. CONGRESS MEMBER.
SENATOR, PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR
HURTADO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. NOT
YET. SENATOR WE'RE GOING TO TRY
A DIFFERENT MIC. WE'RE HAVING
SOME DIFFICULTIES WITH MIKES
TODAY. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. FELLOW MEMBERS, IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY'S
FLOOR SESSION IN LOVING MEMORY
OF MY DEAR FRIEND JOHN VIGNA,
WHO TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL 29, 2024. JOHN HAD A LONG
AND SUCCESSFUL CAREER IN THE
CAPITOL AND IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. HE SPENT A CAREER
FIGHTING FOR WORKERS AND THE
UNDERDOG, WORKING FOR SPEAKER
JOHN PEREZ, LORENA GONZALEZ,
FIONA MÀ AND EVENTUALLY THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY. HE
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA YOUNG DEMOCRATS, THE
SAC COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES ALCOHOL AND
DRUG ADVISORY BOARD, THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO RACIAL PROFILING
COMMISSION WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE CAPITOL LGBT C¯
ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS MANY
OTHER POSTS. JOHN VIGNA STORY
BEGAN IN REDDING, CALIFORNIA,
WHERE HE WAS BORN AND RAISED. HE
FIRST STOOD OUT IN HIGH SCHOOL
AS A BRILLIANT STUDENT OF
HISTORY AND GOVERNMENT. JOHN
ALWAYS LISTENS BEFORE HE SPEAKS,
SAID MIKE MOYNIHAN. HIS HIGH
SCHOOL GOVERNMENT AND ECONOMICS
INSTRUCTOR, WHO CALLED VIGNA ONE
OF HIS ALL TIME TOP STUDENTS.
BUT BEFORE HIS ASTRONOMICAL RISE
AS A CAPITOL STAFFER, VIGNA
ASTOUNDED HIS NORTH STATE
NEIGHBORS BY MOUNTING A CREDIBLE
CAMPAIGN FOR REDDING CITY
COUNCIL. HE WAS AN 18 YEAR OLD
SHOE. HE WAS AN 18 YEAR OLD SHOE
SALESMAN AT MERVYN'S, FRESH OUT
OF ENTERPRISE HIGH SCHOOL, WHO
CHOSE THEMES THAT RESONATED WITH
THE ELECTORATE. HE FINISHED IN
THE MIDDLE OF A CROWDED FIELD,
EARNING OVER 3500 VOTES, LEAVING
AN IMPRESSION ON FORMER RECORD
SEARCHLIGHT EDITOR TOM KEENE,
WHO PENNED AN EDITORIAL CALLING
VIGNA SAVVY BEYOND HIS YEARS.
JOHN FIRST CAME TO THE CAPITAL
REGION IN 2003, WHEN HE LEFT
REDDING TO COMPLETE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, SACRAMENTO. HE
FURTHER BLOSSOMED DURING HIS
TIME HERE, LIVING AS AN OPENLY
GAY MAN FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HIS LIFE. HE LANDED AN
INTERNSHIP WITH THEN SECRETARY
OF STATE KELLY SHELLEY, LEARNING
THE ROPES FIRSTHAND AND
PARLAYING THE EXPERIENCE INTO A
CAREER THAT SAW HIM SERVING
MULTIPLE MEMBERS FROM CAROLE
MIGDEN TO NICOLE PARRA. I FIRST
CROSSED PATHS WITH JOHN VIGNA
AROUND THIS TIME WHEN I TWO CAME
TO SAC STATE FOR MY
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE. WE
IMMEDIATELY BONDED OVER BEING
DEMOCRATS FROM RURAL CALIFORNIA,
JOHN WAS MY GUIDING LIGHT. HE
HELPED ME LAND MY FIRST
INTERNSHIP AT THE CAPITOL,
ENCOURAGED ME TO FURTHER GET
INVOLVED, AND MENTORED ME ALONG
THE WAY AS I ENTERED INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE. HIS COMMITMENT TO FIGHT
FOR CLEAN WATER FURTHER UNITED
US WHEN REFLECTING ON A BILL HE
ONCE WORKED ON. IN 2009, WHICH
REQUIRED A WORKING CLASS CITY OF
MAYWOOD TO CLEANSE ITS DRINKING
WATER OF MANGANESE AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS, JOHN SAID A LOT OF
THE TIME, GOVERNMENT DOES THINGS
AND YOU DON'T SEE THE BENEFIT.
THIS TIME. THE BENEFIT WAS CLEAR
AND UNAMBIGUOUS. THAT
COMMITMENT, THAT COMMITMENT TO
MEANINGFUL, TANGIBLE IMPROVEMENT
IN THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS IS
WHAT MADE JOHN SO UNIQUELY
INFLUENTIAL IN THE LIFE OF SO
MANY OF US, COMING UP THROUGH
PUBLIC POLICY CIRCLES. AND IT
WILL STAY WITH ME FOR THE REST
OF MY LIFE. IN ADDITION TO HIS
NUMEROUS PROFESSIONAL AND
PERSONAL SUCCESSES, HE WOULD
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT HE PUT HIS
EXPANSIVE KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY
AND TRIVIA TO USE AS A CHAMPION
ON JEOPARDY! BOTH AS A ONE DAY
CHAMPION AND AS A WILD CARD
QUARTERFINALIST. BUT BECAUSE OF
JOHN'S CONSTANT DESIRE TO HELP
OTHERS AND ADVOCACY FOR ORGAN
DONATION, HIS FAMILY GRACIOUSLY
DONATED HIS ORGANS TO ALLOW
OTHERS ANOTHER CHANCE AT LIFE.
JOHN'S LEGACY AND LONG LIST OF
ACCOLADES DURING HIS TIME IN
SACRAMENTO AND BEYOND WILL
FOREVER LIVE ON IN THE HEARTS
AND MINDS OF MANY OF HIS
FRIENDS, BUT ALSO IN THE
HALLWAYS OF THIS CAPITOL. WE
MISS HIM DEARLY, MOURN HIS
ABSENCE, AND WE WILL CHERISH OUR
TIME SPENT HIM FOR THE REST OF
OUR DAYS FOR THESE REASONS AND
SO MANY MORE, I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF JOHN
GARRETT VIGNA. THANK YOU FOR
SHOWING HIS SHARING HIS STORY
WITH US. SENATOR. PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO THAT WE MAY
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
SENATOR ATKINS, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO JOIN MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE AND RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JOHN VIGNA.
ALSO, I FIRST MET JOHN WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND HE WAS
WORKING FOR THEN SPEAKER JOHN Ã
PEREZ. AND AS SOMEONE WHO ALSO
WORKED FOR AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
PREVIOUSLY, I HAVE TO SAY THAT
JOHN OR VIGNA, AS WE
AFFECTIONATELY CALLED HIM, WAS A
STAFF PERSON. STAFF PERSON,
TALENTED, HARD WORKING AND
COMMITTED. HE WAS TREMENDOUSLY
GIFTED. AS MY COLLEAGUE ALREADY
SAID, AS A WRITER. AND HE WAS
THOUGHTFUL, CARING AS A PERSON
TO EVERYONE. AND THOSE ARE THE
REASONS HE WAS SO EFFECTIVE IN
HIS WORK, WHETHER IT WAS HELPING
PEOPLE GET AS ALREADY INDICATED,
SAFE DRINKING WATER OR HELPING
MORE STUDENTS AFFORD COLLEGE.
ALTHOUGH A YOUNG MAN HIMSELF,
JOHN WAS ALSO A DEDICATED MENTOR
TO OTHERS, PARTICULARLY THROUGH
YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND BY BECOMING
A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE CAPITOL
LGBTQ QUÊ ASSOCIATION, AND TO
OUR COLLEAGUE WHO REPRESENTS THE
CITY OF REDDING. JOHN WAS A
PROUD SON OF THAT COMMUNITY AND
SPOKE ABOUT IT OFTEN. I KNOW
THAT THERE WAS A WONDERFUL
CELEBRATION OF HIS LIFE AT THE
END OF LAST WEEK, AND APPRECIATE
SO MUCH ALL OF US BEING ABLE TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF A LOCAL HERO AND BASEBALL
LEGEND, SEAN BURROUGHS. SEAN
BURROUGHS WAS A STAR ATHLETE AT
JUST 12 YEARS OLD IN LONG BEACH.
A TWO TIME LITTLE LEAGUE WORLD
CHAMPION WHO PITCHED BACK TO
BACK NO HITTERS IN THE LITTLE
LEAGUE WORLD SERIES. BURROUGHS
WAS LAUNCHED INTO THE SPOTLIGHT
AS A KID JUST FOR THAT REASON.
HIS LONG BEACH SQUADS WINS IN
1992 AND 93 MADE THEM THE FIRST
AMERICAN TEAM TO WIN THE LLWS
BACK TO BACK. IN 2000, SEAN
PLAYED BASEBALL IN THE SUMMER
OLYMPICS, WINNING A GOLD MEDAL
WITH THE US TEAM. DRAFTED WITH
THE NINTH OVERALL PICK IN THE
1998 MLB DRAFT BY THE SAN DIEGO
PADRES, SEAN WOULD PLAY SEVEN
MLB SEASONS WITH THE PADRES. THE
TAMPA BAY RAYS, THEN KNOWN AS
THE DEVIL RAYS, ARIZONA
DIAMONDBACKS, AND MINNESOTA
TWINS, FINISHING A CAREER 0.278
BATTING AVERAGE, 12 HOME RUNS,
AND 143 RUNS BATTED IN. HE WAS
JUST RECENTLY PASSED AWAY, AS HE
WAS ACTUALLY AT A LITTLE LEAGUE
GAME FOR HIS YOUNG CHILD ABOUT
SIX SEVEN YEARS OLD. THE SAME
ABOUT THE SAME AGE AS MY CHILD,
JUST IN A PARK. HE WAS FOUND.
UNFORTUNATELY UNRESPONSIVE, AND
SO HIS FAMILY MOURNS HIM. THE
LONG BEACH COMMUNITY MOURNS HIM
AND THE LONG BEACH LITTLE LEAGUE
BASEBALL COMMUNITY MOURNS HIM.
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY AND OFFER DEEP
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, FOR SHARING A
STORY WITH US. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO THAT WE MAY
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
SENATORS, WE'RE ASKING FOR A 1
TO 2 MINUTE BREAK IF WE CAN STAY
ON THE FLOOR 1 TO 2 MINUTES, WE
WILL RECONVENE IN A COUPLE OF
MINUTES.
SENATORS, WE HAVE ONE FINAL
INTRODUCTION TODAY OF A SPECIAL
GUEST UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. WE HAVE SENATOR
PORTANTINO. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENT. IT
IS INDEED AN HONOR. COLLEAGUES
AND A GREAT PLEASURE THAT I
INTRODUCE ACTOR, DIRECTOR,
PRODUCER AND DEDICATED ARTS
ADVOCATE, THE INCOMPARABLE DANNY
GLOVER. WELL, MR. GLOVER MAY BE
WELL KNOWN FOR STARRING IN
LETHAL WEAPON AND ITS SUBSEQUENT
SEQUELS. HE HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF TAKING PART IN AND SUPPORTING
THE ARTS. MR. GLOVER STUDIED
ACTING AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
AND TRAINED AT THE BLACK ACTOR'S
WORKSHOP OF THE AMERICAN
CONSERVATORY OF THEATER. FROM
THEATER, HE MADE THE JUMP TO
FILM AND TELEVISION AND HAS HAD
A CAREER FULL OF HONORS,
INCLUDING MULTIPLE PRIMETIME
EMMY AWARD NOMINATIONS AND
SCREEN ACTORS GUILD NOMINATIONS,
AND HE RECENTLY RECEIVED THE
JEAN HERSHOLT HUMANITARIAN AWARD
FROM THE ACADEMY OF MOTION
PICTURE AND ARTS. MR. GLOVER HAS
THAT RARE DISTINCTION AS AN
ACTOR OF BEING WELL KNOWN AND
SUCCESSFUL IN ACTION MOVIES,
DRAMATIC MOVIES, COMEDIC MOVIES,
AND HAS BROUGHT TO LIFE MANY,
WONDERFUL ANIMATED CHARACTERS AS
WELL AS, YOU KNOW, I LIKE
TRIVIA, AND MR. GLOVER IS ONE OF
ONLY THREE ACTORS, ONE OF ONLY
THREE ACTORS TO HAVE SURVIVED
HAND TO HAND COMBAT WITH THE
PREDATOR. THINK OF THAT. ONLY
THREE PEOPLE HAVE GONE TOE TO
TOE WITH THE PREDATOR AND
SURVIVED, AND HE'S ONE OF THEM.
CAN ANYONE NAME THE OTHER TWO?
FORMER GOVERNOR ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER AND ADRIEN BRODY.
MR. GLOVER AND I ALSO HAVE A FUN
CONNECTION. CAN ANYONE GUESS
WHAT THAT MIGHT BE? NOW? I HAVE
NOT BEEN IN ANY FILMS NOMINATED
FOR BEST PICTURE LIKE MR.
GLOVER, BUT HE APPEARED IN THE
FILM THE COLOR PURPLE IN 1985.
AND LAST YEAR MY DAUGHTER WORKED
ON THE COLOR PURPLE, THE MUSICAL
MR. GLOVER IS HERE TODAY AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE ARTS. HE HAS
BEEN PART OF THAT SUCCESSFUL
ARTS, CULTURE IN OUR GREAT
STATE, AND IT IS WITH WONDERFUL
DISTINCTION AND PRIDE THAT I
INTRODUCE MR. DANNY GLOVER TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
PLEASE GIVE HIM A BIG ROUND OF
GLOVER. THANK YOU FOR COMING AND
JOINING US. WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE.
ALL RIGHT. GROUP PHOTO TIME.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. CAN
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TAKE PICTURES WITH
THE LEGENDARY DANNY GLOVER. AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT HE IS HERE.
AND FOR HIS ADVOCACY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THE SENATE. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, JUNE 3RD AT 2 P.M. LET'S
KICK OFF THE WEEKEND AND
CELEBRATE THIS AMERICAN ICON,
DANNY GLOVER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY, JUNE 3RD, 2024 AT 2 P.M.